welcome back to new rockstars the
batman's gonna put the world's greatest
detective to test but
will vengeance pattinson just curb stomp
his way out of it
oh this is the big question
this is my coors light i promise yeah
we're we'll put that in post
no john enough taste the rockies
we put too much on taunting yeah john i
need you to cgi this out of my hand
make my hand look open and then put the
cannon
[Music]
the big question is a podcast that gives
you too much information about how
batman's detective work is actually not
at all what you'd want a detective to do
in real life
i see you like cutting the eyes out of
photos of women
my son is a big fan of that too and
what's gonna happen when a zodiac style
maniac actually makes him use his brain
yeah i'm excited the the world's
greatest detective that gets his
uh the people he's supposedly protecting
very injured or kidnapped or
put into cases of peril or just half of
them perfectly burned right down the
side
yeah a very a very asymmetrical burn
seared perfectly down the center
absolutely i'm eric boss here with me to
analyze batman's detective work is
upstate new york's 10-time prosecution
sidestepper tommy bechtol that's right
if the
zweigle's white hot dog does not fit you
must acquit
that's a very regionally specific uh
that's the rochester equivalent of uh
that's right
well matt reeves the batman film appears
to take a cue from detective
noir stories like seven chinatown many
are realizing that despite being
credited as the world's greatest
detective
when it comes to actual detective work
batman's record is
kind of a mixed bag so tommy our big
question for you
this week is is the batman actually
a good detective ah that's a great
question and allow me to become a
detective and ask some questions like
what makes a good detective well good
detectives observe research interview
find patterns are able to keep an open
mind
follow the evidence etc they do that
this is not the detective i know from
watching tv in films my detectives drink
real hard they beat people up
yes and at the end of the day you love
them despite them having
no real family to come home to dead
parents
and they also notice one little thing
wrong with whoever the most famous guest
star is
and then they solve the case like wait a
second
jean smart has a feather on her pillow
but she said she was allergic to birds
all right
great job colombo you solved it they are
so they do their homework unlike me who
had to repeat multiple grades and
only was able to pass this class is when
daddy put up money
they don't work backwards from
pre-formed conclusions good detectives
collaborate
with the community other state agencies
and
witnesses in order to build their cases
bad detectives do
just enough homework pulling a bechtold
to justify
hunting down someone their gut tells
them is guilty
bad detectives are violent and violate
civil liberties
bad detectives go at it alone lone
wolves you know
any of this mean anything to you
so what we're going to do today is we're
going to review past cases of batman's
work
and we're gonna grade him uh based on
the the you know the true world's
greatest detectives the scooby gang
mystery team a plus detective work will
be velma
b will be a fred caliber detective
c c will be scooby d will be shaggy
and wait so scooby's higher than i guess
that makes sense that
dog who can talk is definitely a better
detective than a stoner
who's constantly running away from
everything i found some candles
that's right and by the way daphne's not
even on this scale
yeah well daphne's useless she just says
scooby doo where are you and then gets
tied up
most of the time and of course receiving
a falling grade is
old man jenkins
so i guess the worst detective is the
one who's trying to pretend to be a
ghost to scare
kids off of a property he wants and he
would have gotten away with that is kind
of what a lot of batman are is they wear
masks and they use
fear to scare people away from things
that's right that's the world's worst
detective and they're always blaming the
kids in their life like robin i would
have gotten away with it
if it weren't for that damn clown if it
weren't for you
and damien wayne my son uh
all right so first case
that's the people's court music
hush which was a 2002 2003 comic series
and a 2019
banger of an animated film many people
uh believe that matt reeves is
gonna pull from the hush storylines for
his upcoming movie so the mystery
being solved is a man with a bandage
face is masterminding and manipulating
all of gotham's villains
in a plot against batman so yeah
what are batman's detective skills that
he puts to use here well batman
smartly observes the out-of-character
behavior of catwoman you know
bad gal that makes him a little horny so
he finds clues
such as the fact that only someone with
familiarity with the batmobile
could shoot out its tire that's the weak
point in there most of the time you
can't really shoot those out but there
is like one
access point and he notices that a
little a little death a little weakness
in the death story but we're not gonna
i'm not gonna
say that they stole from star wars here
so he doesn't let his notions blind him
too much from the truth
he does sometimes get a little off track
in this uh saga but
he's also suffering from a brain injury
for much of it and as someone who
received
two concussions from football it's hard
to remember stuff once you get hurt in
the head yeah
yeah now where was i
[Music]
tommy come back to us batman coach i
can't i can't play coach i can't play
i don't have got enough left to the
table wake up tommy tommy the year is 20
20.
a darker timeline than where you came
from so maybe you want to go back to it
well listen i was about to make a
terrible joke that would have been
edited out and i just
won't so finally he uses his great
deduction to realize the riddler's
agenda and in the end he outsmarts the
riddler
into keeping his identity a secret which
i mean that's uh that's pretty
intelligent it was like the world's
greatest riddle
is uh one that people don't know the
answer to so riddler's like
damn you know it's such a great little
moment there at the end of hush
hush is like one of my favorite batman
graphic novels because he like
he actually is smart enough and dumb
enough he's like an accurate detective
and he uses smart detective work
detective skills so that like when he
fails it makes sense when he succeeds it
makes sense
yes pretty amazing with that cumulative
detective body of work we give this one
a full
on grade a velma we give this one yeah
sure
the full velma which you usually have to
pay for to get but
this one is a free full velma for you
all right case two yeah and
we're talking this one is gonna blow the
doors off this courtroom case two is
the classic film batman forever 1995.
why are we talking about this one this
is the last time batman actually faced
the riddler on the big screen so
yeah i guess in live action for sure
yeah let's yeah let's talk about batman
forever because that is an interesting
one
and as i've said paul dano is the jim
carrey of his time
the riddler played by a jim carrey in
what created
a million halloween costumes with the
between the like
fluorescent future hair and the green
body suit i know i owned it and i don't
have a body for a body suit so everybody
oh so the wardrobe on that film
is wild like uh he's got a light up it
keeps me safe when i'm
jogging at night yes absolutely and the
question marks i mean i gotta tell you
it was like the closest thing you could
buy at walmart to being like a set
accurate costume because the real was
it was literally just a leotard anyway
yeah uh the river played by jim carrey
uh
taunts batman with clues about his
identity as he
and two-face played by tommy lee jones
robbed businesses
around gotham at the same time bruce's
former employee circulates the
brain-draining vox
around the city so yes oh okay so yes
you know it is interesting looking back
on that movie
the point of the clues was to just screw
with batman to be like
can you guess who i am like it directly
contradicts
what the riddler edward enigma is trying
to do with like
learn all of gotham secrets through his
you know uh
telecom tech yeah bit self-destructive
it
is more of a like uh stalkery thing like
he just wanted to be noticed
by batman all right so in this one let's
look at his detective skills
and they're not great batman is a
passive investigator waiting to respond
until the riddler delivers clues
directly to him
literally into his back i guess it's
true he doesn't really go after him he
just kind of is like oh another crime
scene oh
thank god there's a clue here the
riddles are relatively simple i remember
solving them as like a teenager
or you know i think i don't even think i
was a teenager at this point batman
deduces an
easy-to-find numeric pattern that
translates into the riddler's name
by the way a good detective would have
made the riddler edward enigma
connection
weeks earlier and by then yeah it was
too late the damage had been yeah and
that alphanumeric
thing was bizarre like it honestly felt
like eric cartman putting the numbers
together to make everything 911. like
18 is ah
e how about mr e
mystery and another name for mystery
enigma
sequence two minus one is one one one
eleven
two minus one is one one one and there
are nine members on silverstein's board
of directors that's
nine one one nine eleven it was cool in
95
and now looking back on it oh that's why
q anon exists
[Music]
yes exactly and by then he had already
killed my dear friend ed begley jr so it
was too late to save him
and if you kill ed you crossed me and
that's just simply a line too far we're
giving batman
uh for that death alone we're giving him
a d which is a registered shaggy
yeah it makes sense because you gotta
imagine uh
val kilmer's approach while he is a very
smart batman to that world
his investigative work is seems a bit
stoned
it seems like he's not really trying
that hard he doesn't seem like that
eager to solve and sleuth out the case
no he's not a very good detective in
this story
no no no case number three this one's a
classic
aren't they all though but this one
really is the long halloween
1996-1997 series is another great comic
story line that
people are thinking that reeves film
might be taking elements of for
for its story inspiration at least so
the mystery is
the holiday killer has a new victim
every major holiday i mean are we
including like secretary's day here i
don't know
it feels like it's national dog day once
a month by the way side tangent they
should only get one day
marking the jets with festive
decorations and leaving behind a 22
caliber
pistol with a rubber baby bottle nipple
as a silencer
notable mob figures are usually the
targets of of the holiday killers
one of the more interesting uh villains
that we've seen in batman comics
an interesting gimmick for sure a bit
ahead of its time
yeah and the baby bottle uh thing is is
just such a fun
thing because it's a literal silencer
for babies you know
like shut them up crying but it's like a
silencer on the gun so there's like a
lot of layers to this it was just really
fun to read
yeah okay so this was one of the first
times we saw batman do
actual police work uh alongside gotham
pd
and the district attorneys it was pretty
grounded also many city authorities are
painted as corrupt in this one which has
become a huge
huge theme in batman both tv the gotham
tv show and comic books since then i
feel like there's almost
always some corrupt elements uh batman
interviews the calendar man to get
hannibal lecter style insight so that
was
that was a really cool sequence in that
uh batman cleverly predicts
holliday's next move and stages a trap
for him so that's
you know that's showing the actual uh
willingness to learn
the behaviors and habits and instead of
just following a gut feeling
and this all ends with holiday getting
unmasked as alberto falcone
yeah carmine's son uh batman did not see
that coming
he he yeah he missed it he missed it um
overall though
pretty solid detective work like the
fact that like the things that he does
are not
goofy right you know other versions of
batman that we've seen
right he's not just fighting his way out
of it he's thinking he's applying
real detective work the fact that he
goes back to interview yeah calendar man
it does feel like a silence of the
lamb's move that the real fbi would do
you were doing fine you had been
courteous and
receptive to courtesy now this
ham-handed segway into your
questionnaire
it was it was just such a grounded story
this really did feel like one of the
world's greatest detective type stories
for batman
i did i i enjoyed it and the grade that
i ultimately had to give him here is a b
uh we're giving him a fred a handsome
fred but the reason i gave him a b is
because by the time
batman really uncovered the mystery of
who holliday
the holiday killer was harvey dent had
already become the real threat
as he had turned into two-face so yeah
yeah so within the
within the confines of the story he did
fail he did fail
if we're judging like was this a good
detective story absolutely a plus
detective story yeah but the character
was just
too much of a step behind is he the
world's greatest detective in that story
yes no he fails he lets two-face be
created yes
okay now to avoid any recency bias we're
gonna go to our next case which is
batman v superman colon
dawn of justice colin the ultimate
edition
and um the reason we're gonna cover this
is this is the
most recent time we saw batman try to
solve a mystery in a movie
so the mystery is criminals are planning
for the arrival of the white portuguese
in gotham yes a code name batman is
trying to determine the meaning of
you know isn't that interesting that
that is the mystery in the first act of
batman v
superman but because there was so much
in that movie and the movie becomes
about his like
anger and his fight with batman we just
kind of forget about the whole white
portuguese
part of it yeah and it's just about like
oh he's he's trying to figure out ways
to weaponize kryptonite
yeah and then he learns that he doesn't
have to fight superman because her
parents have the same name
why did you say that
and then they both they all work
together it's the white portuguese was
the mystery plot
we kind of broke it right well i'm sure
if we just give snyder a few more cuts
at it he'll be able to weave that in a
little more seamlessly
that would totally be worth our time to
petition for anyway
let's take a look at the detective
skills that were put on display in this
movie
batman tortures low-level gang members
by burning a bat brand into their skin
to get information by the way with the
with a proper
civil lawyer you know if you if you
actually had a lawyer that would
file a petition i believe that bruce
wayne could be bankrupted by this if
they could talk
for sure into batman and prove that he
branded
them with like if they could figure out
the technology that was used to brand
them even if they don't figure out that
bruce wayne is batman
but that it was something from wayne
tech that branded him that way i think
they could take
bruce wayne down financially for this
yeah absolutely for
negligence it's kind of like how people
would sue gun manufacturers whenever a
shooting would happen you know like
there's probably a judge who would hold
wayne corp and negligence for that
absolutely
because today is a day for truth
i believe you
so and as a result of them having those
brands they get killed imprisoned which
he
shrugs off and says we're criminals
alfred
that's right he doesn't really care
basically the all lives don't matter of
batman
not nihilism so when he learns that the
white portuguese is just a beautiful
boat he pursues the criminals shipping
the cargo in a deadly chase which again
he doesn't really have any regard for
human life in this movie
he works alone he refuses really
anyone's help other than a very snarky
alfred who really looks like he's more
annoyed that that he has to hang out
with batman and bruce wayne
than anything else this is just maybe a
jeremy irons you know delivery thing
because i love jeremy irons but he
definitely is fantastic in that movie
but
i agree it definitely feels more like
year 15 of a marriage between the two of
them and they're just like
i don't even like to look at you anymore
i don't even like the look on your face
when you breathe it bothers me when we
would lie in bed together sometimes i
would look at you and see her and just
feel so gross
i felt repulsed when you touched your
slob they're definitely sleeping in
separate beds
absolutely i mean one might be sleeping
in a cave for all we know so anyway like
i said
he's working alone and then he steals
the cargo from lex luthor
the kryptonite in order to build a
weapon of mass destruction and take out
superman literally the savior of the
world look
i guess you could argue that this batman
is not based on the world's greatest
detective batman he's based on the dark
knight returns batman who is just like
an
angry old man who's trying to kill
superman makes sense yeah
but why include the detective plot at
all at that point
in the story so honestly the better
investigator in that movie is clark kent
because
in the you know ultimate edition we
absolutely see him do some
interesting investigative work and we
see him he's uh he's the world's
greatest detective
of batman v superman um but yeah for
sure the ben affleck batman we don't
really get to see him do a lot of good
detective work in the dcu
so obviously if you haven't figured out
by the shredding we just gave this
his grade is a old man jenkins
he is an old man yeah he is the old man
jacobs who's scaring the [ __ ] out of
everyone
he's kind of a bad guy and i would have
gotten away with it if it weren't for
you lois lane and that meddling jimmy
olsen that got assassinated in the first
five minutes of the movie yeah he's good
in other ways
he's a awesome batman to watch fight
watch to crush people's skulls and he's
he's kind of fun
ben affleck does a great job playing
like the smug just kind of [ __ ] talking
of batman to superman but he is not a
good detective at all we should not be
taking any lessons learned
from this batman this is the batman she
tells you not to worry about
versus the uh whatever that meme is the
man she tells you not to worry about
this is the batman
we tell you not to worry about anyway
case number five
we're taking it back we're taking it way
back to gotham by gaslight
not only written over 30 years ago now
uh but also taking place
in a bygone era this was also adapted
into a 2018
animated film yeah that's right they
loosely adapted it into a
kind of some similar plot points but the
final reveal was different and this also
was adapted into a conversation piece on
my bookshelf which is my most frequent
uh can i browse that what is that about
followed by me telling them what it's
about fall but i'm going i'll just
borrow the killing joke again
so anyway the reason we're going to talk
about this one is
with reeves batman having zodiac
parallels this is batman's most famous
run-in
with a real-life serial killer jack the
ripper so the setting for the mystery is
this it's an
elseworld victorian-era gotham jack the
ripper has arrived
and is murdering young women many
believe jack to be batman
sure and batman is tried and convicted
for the crime
batman must unmask the real killer in
order to save himself
and the still living women of gotham who
would like not to be murdered it's such
a great story it's such a cool what if
uh thought experiment that it's really
really fun setting oh by the way
i encourage people to borrow it off my
bookshelf they just usually are like
victorian era we don't like things that
we can't visualize as a time when we
were alive oh it's like the perfect era
though and like in the
the comics it's you know it's exploring
jack the ripper if it were in gotham
but like in the movie it ends up going
to the world's fair which feels like
it's based on the
the city of chicago world yeah turn of
the century which
had like the most famous american killer
you could argue hh homes
so it feels like it's like the coolest
setting if you're into
dark serial killer yeah non-fiction
absolutely
so in the comics jack the ripper ends up
being batman's attorney
uncle jake packer and in the movie
believe it or not the jack the ripper is
actually revealed to be jim gordon
kind of yeah that's right yeah he's got
this cool monologue about like clearing
the filth out of gotham and it has to do
with like his wife driven insane
oh yeah oh it's always the wives that
drive
that go insane that make men kill isn't
it they're always doing it on behalf of
their insane wives that
definitely didn't ask them to so in the
comics batman deduces that jack the
ripper must
have been a surgeon who worked with his
father the movie is a bit crazier he
only figures out that jim gordon is jack
the ripper
by relying on selena kyle some luck and
a houdini handcuff trick
i paid houdini 300 for that trick
so going on our earlier standards of
what makes a good detective and a bad
detective he does some decent detective
work but he also relies on the old gut
feeling and a little bit of luck this is
like a very tv
detective level mystery solved so we're
going to give him
a perfect down the middle c a scooby c
red ripper
you don't get a ray scooby you get every
case
number six the dark knight trilogy
uh three movies that came out in 2005
2008 and 2012
all directed by noted director
christopher nolan i don't know if you've
heard of me these are considered by
both me and eric and a lot of other
people the best batman films i'm just
kidding i'm not putting words in eric's
mouth
but they're no no i agree i think they
are the best batman films is he the best
batman no but
it's the best like the best stories that
we've seen i
i completely agree so what we're going
to figure out here what we're hoping to
see is
is will will pattinson's batman be a
better detective
than uh bill's batman in the nolan
versus okay well what's the standard
how good of a detective was bail's
batman
bales batman was i would say
detective work-wise he certainly used
his relationship with jim gordon like
they definitely he worked with
the with the gotham city police
department and also
subversively against the gotham police
department when him and jim went rogue
but like
he was definitely he definitely worked
his best when he worked with others
right like the bell batman definitely
embraced the team spirit the attack yeah
and resources were off the charts for
him i i don't remember a lot of gut
instinct you know i i was he seemed to
be kind of by the book right like he had
a code
that he repeated to selena kyle no guys
he was kind of a rule abiding batman
yeah and batman begins or in two of the
movies he had to do with the league of
shadows and both times he does not see
the league of shadows coming
at all right i would say in the dark
knight the joker
ends up kind of winning right like he
terrorizes gotham and batman kind of has
to
become the villain by the end of that
film he's super heroic i would say that
that is true
up until the point that he chooses not
to kill the joker because that is
clearly the outcome the joker wanted
well sure yeah the chaos he knew that if
if he could get batman to kill him in my
opinion how i interpret it was
if that if batman decided to kill the
joker then he would be forever lost as a
hero
he would be you know he would always be
this kind of like
ruthless gotham would never see him as a
savior they'd always fear him
so anyway the detective skills and
batman begins batman is completely
blindsided by roswell ghoul's return
and relies on lucious fox's antidote
yeah lucious is kind of the hero of the
story heroes
story there absolutely and i think that
might have been deliberate as that's the
kind of a character that people were
less familiar with you know like it
that was going to be in all three movies
so i think having him kind of you know
put the hammer down in the first one was
like maybe a deliberate thing by
a far off vision by olin and be like
we're establishing lucius fox as a like
pillar of these films
so in dark knight he cooperates with
dent and gordon he uses smart forensics
to track the joker but
he does violate civil liberties to
extradite lao and
yeah and beat up the joker in the
interrogation room so yeah you can't do
that
that is uh he does lose his cool
absolutely he's also spying on everyone
uh in the city right he just like
patriot acts the entire city of gotham
he violates everyone's fourth amendment
rights there and then dark knight rises
he doesn't see bane or italia coming at
all i mean he literally sleeps with
italian which
i mean listen we've all been blinded by
a beautiful woman before
you know it's happened yeah but not a
not a good detective in in that movie no
no bail batman is heroic but not a good
detective
his best work is accomplished between uh
batman begins and dark knight yeah it's
kind of like we don't see it on screen
when batman begins ends and the dark
knight begins it's implied that there's
been a lot of good detective work in
between those
maybe just nolan found the detective
work side of it boring like he does use
the ballistics we see it in montage
but it's never like the big relevatory
moment where it's like aha
right i don't know if nolan was as
interested in that side of the character
yeah i think with with all of that it's
tough because i think at certain points
he is a good detective and does exercise
a lot of the good skills that we talked
about but he also does so many
mistaken or bad or irresponsible things
that in the end i kind of feel like it
all averages out into a c a solid scooby
c
i think that's fair yeah and you know a
lot of this came up because we
we saw this twitter thread kind of a hot
take of a guy saying that nowadays we
want to see a good detective story
batman how do you make uh batman a good
detective
in the modern age because yeah a lot of
what we've seen on screen is batman just
like
beating the crap out of people violating
people's rights yeah um
being like a kind of a corrupt cop and
you know
kind of elevating that kind of behavior
so people thinking that's what a good
hero is so how do you make a good batman
how could pattinson uh batman be a
better detective
and be a true detective that people are
like this is what we should
identify with as as good heroic
detective work
yep i saw that i enjoyed that threat it
was it was very
thought-provoking well and i think he
kind of brought up the idea of making
joe chill a cop
yeah that's how you do it it's like now
batman's enemy
is like the corruption within gotham pd
i think that's one way to go
i think another way to go is just like i
mean nolan
started to do a bit like how you know
joe chill got off
right and it was like an example the
corruption of the criminal justice
system but i think if they lean more
into that and really show how the gotham
pd are kind of like
not helpful in this process yeah um and
also it seems like this batman film is
gonna explore how the wayne family has
played such a huge role in the
corruption of the city
so it seems like they're already going
in that direction and uh
and they're gonna have this um jeffrey
wright gotham pd series on hbo
you know they're gonna explore issues of
like police brutality yeah
oh yeah like there's no way hbo is gonna
do this story and not lean into those
things no
no they have to i think and i think
that'll be really interesting and
hopefully done
i i have no reason to believe that won't
be done in a way that is compelling
without feeling like it's uh exploit
exploitative you know yeah and ripped
too close to headlines right now you
know that make us uncomfortable to watch
it so
it's definitely going to be a tightrope
dance and i admire them for trying for
sure
yeah but it still looks like this
pattinson beats the crap out of people
you got in way too many punches on that
dude
so it's gonna be a tightrope they're
gonna lean to both ways a bit but i hope
at the end of the day
this is a batman that has some kind of
like a reckoning with his own
soul how he looks inward rather than
just like blaming society for being
wrong
which is what nolan ultimately did also
i'm starting to sweat like a bat symbol
in the middle of my shirt because i
turned my air conditioning off to uh
not make a sound so that's how all
batman
begins this is my best sweating his logo
yes exactly
a fear it's a symbol no guns
no sweating all right all right well
thank you for breaking that down i think
we learned that
batman as we've seen in the comics could
be a fascinating detective in the movies
there's still
stories to be told about how great of a
detective batman can be
yeah but before we continue with some
bite size questions i'm going to answer
we want to thank our friends
at coors light for helping us make this
episode you notice i've been
taking strategic sips of it for the past
half hour
[Music]
look the reason why we've been loving
working with coors this summer
is we all have a lot of stressors in our
lives right now word hustle family stuff
trying to keep from going crazy
sometimes we just need to hit pause and
take a moment to joe chill
but not joe chill just this average joe
chill and when we do we grab a chorus
light
and it is the beer that is literally
made to chill and uh you've been seeing
it throughout this episode
the mountain glows blue that's how you
know your beer is cold
like the rockies ready to chill and sit
tommy i know you're a big fan of poor's
late
i am in god knows now more than ever i
could use one down here but
unfortunately uncle doug got to the mini
fridge last night and pounded them all
in what i can only call
a dramatic episode so i'm here sipping
water like a chump
trying to get these sweat marks off when
the cold blue dr manhattan style
mountains could chill me
permanently well not to rub it on your
face but coors light is the one i choose
when i need to unwind so when you and
hit reset everyone watching reach for
the beer that's made to chill get coors
light and the new look delivered
straight to your door
at get dot coorslight.com celebrate
responsibly coors brewing company golden
colorado
we also want to thank our friends at
hero health for helping us make this
episode it's kind of hard to remember to
take medication right
when i wake up in a cold sweat thinking
about old cap roaming the streets this
guy's still alive in our timeline how
it's possible
it's dancing with the old ladies taking
my girlfriend away from me the last
thing on my mind
is taking some pills well hero is your
medicine cabinet reinvented
the hero pill dispenser sorts all daily
medications and delivers them all with a
push of a button if medication isn't
taken the hero app will send a
notification to you a family member a
caregiver so a dose is never missed hero
makes it simple and easy to make sure
you or your loved ones stay on track and
get the right meds at the right time
every time your hero membership includes
the app the pill dispenser
and 24 7 support for just a dollar a day
hero even has an optional service that
delivers medication directly to your
door
never miss a dose again and always have
peace of mind with hero
[Music]
and right now if you go to
herohealth.com big question
you'll get 50 off that's five zero
percent off initiation fee
and a 30 day risk free trial with a
money back guarantee
that's herohealth.com bigquestion to
start your membership with 50
off and a 30 day free trial don't forget
that zerohealth.com
bigquestion all right well we've
answered some big questions and now it's
time for some cute
little bite-sized questions
that eric will answer yeah baby
all right let me make sure i'm saying
this right a jaisal
a jaisal on discord asks marvel vs dc
other than marvel
taking the idea for thanos from dc's
dark side
awkward who ripped off or stole
characters
more from each other okay yeah that that
is an example and let's be clear about
something
when we say stole you can say the
publishers stole but a lot of times
these are the same
artists going back and forth like jim
starlin went back and forth a lot of
people you know
worked for both companies but um we
should also say that both marvel and dc
comic book characters were often just
imitations of figures from ancient
mythology
from from horror genres from other
literature from ghost stories
and they're like yeah that would work as
a character um not to say plagiarism
is uh completely inexcusable but like
i would say in most of the time neither
marvel nor dc
is really the true originator of what
you love about these characters
but um to answer your question i
do have to say that marvel silver age
definitely has a worse track record for
ripping off dc golden age characters
there's just no debate there i mean you
could argue marvel made them better
but in the 60s a lot of the characters
you saw in marvel comics were just
basically ripped off versions of what we
saw in dc comics earlier
just to give some examples uh marvel's
doctor strange was essentially dc's dr
fate
marvel's mr fantastic and sue storm were
basically dc's elongated man into dipney
characters who were maybe weren't as
popular you could say marvel made them
more popular but
they didn't originate them i mean marvel
took their speedster quick silver pretty
much from dc's the flash
marvel had ant-man dc previously had the
atom
marvel stole the name captain marvel
from dc
and then i'm like uh and then you ever
got
so much so that dc later had to change
the character's name to shazam
and marvel was so cheap about they're
like his name's not captain marvel it's
mar-vell
capisce and machiavelli all right but by
the way what a glow-up
captain marvel to shazam my god yeah and
then of course like not just speedsters
you have the arrow guys so
green arrow was at dc and then later
marvel's like well ours is hawkeye
but it also went the other direction too
so like marvel had namor
it was one of their oldest characters dc
later invented aquaman and then marvel
had iron man in the 60s
dc later invented the rocket reds which
some people said or you know or ripped
off versions so
it goes both ways marvel's probably a
bit more guilty of it
but um but then you could argue when it
came to the movies dc
tried to steal marvel's whole movie
release strategy right
and it didn't work well for them no
hello darkness my old friend
all right next ruby also on discord asks
why didn't the boys drown translucent
poison him
choke him his skin would be intact but
his windpipe could still be shut off
right
yeah um it is kind of a
it is a bite-sized question for sure um
because it's not very clear
they say that his skin is impenetrable
but he also says like his
body is mostly indestructible like there
is just a moment episode where butcher
and frenchie are debating they mention
all these past attempts by others to
kill translucent
um and and then huey cuts them off but
like i think the point of that
conversation was to say
look dozens of people have tried to kill
translucent using all the obvious ways
and none of them worked
like people tried it just didn't work
maybe because like in addition to being
instructable he's
he can turn invisible and then like slip
out of their hands and kill them
so like yeah i mean maybe you could
argue
even if you did cut off his windpipe or
if you tried to poison him like his
brain wouldn't die from lack of oxygen
or his heart wouldn't go into cardiac
arrest like it's not just his skin
even his organs have some kind of
defensive quality like if they had the
time to forge that carbon fiber bullet
you have to imagine they would have
known other methods they would have
tried other methods if they
thought it would work and when they
shoved the explosive of his butt
i don't know if they knew for sure that
would work just because it had never
been tried before
so it's that unknown that scared
translucent
and made them think like we might
actually have him and when huey hits the
trigger
i i don't know if he knows it will work
so i it's kind of like an
experiment in that moment so i think
that's why they don't try it is they
just don't know
like they've heard of other stories
where people tried certain things and
they aren't going to repeat that same
mistake they get like one shot
to try to kill him once they get him out
of that cage
so yeah i think that's where that comes
in they do get him eventually though if
i'm not mistaken uh
oh yeah they blow him to hell yeah for
sure a really painful way
uh zep o'neil took to youtube and made a
comment and asked
can nightcrawler teleport into people
i love these kind of questions let's get
more of these kind of questions rather
than like comparing one thing from a
universe to another thing of another
universe just ask us from one universe
could it work well nightcrawler looking
through the pages of the x-men comics
has definitely used teleportation to
like
sever a limb sever someone's head but
it's worth remembering that
nightcrawler's body itself is not
indestructible he's made of flesh and
blood the way the rest of us are
if he were to try to do that within
someone else's body he'd probably also
break his own body and explode his own
flesh so
maybe he could but he would also die
right so best
best uh just to be safe and not uh tell
kurt wagner that you want him inside you
that's what i take from that yes always
the best advice yes
all right we got time for one more box
subscribe
and our box subscribes this week tommy
is what's a weird crush you've had on a
celebrity or a fictional character
you know i i love this question i really
thought about it
because obviously like i like most of
the people i thought of i eventually
came around to like they're attractive
people it's hard to like
say but i would say like at times in my
life that i had weird crushes the mom on
boy meets world i was really into
for a while well it's the mother's turn
she had kind of a raspy
voice like a little bit of a like sexy
voice and like you know she's your
friend's mom
she was a great mom you know and then of
course like on the like weirdo front
lola bunny and space jam
triggered a lot of emotions for me that
were like i think for all of us a lot of
uh like
literal jessica rabbit like it's a
rabbit with jessica rabbit's body so
uh that that certainly gave me one of
those unhealthy expectations for what uh
the girls on my basketball team at my
school would look like
so they aren't rabbits they don't have
long ears they can't dunk
that's the big thing like i can't date a
girl who can't dunk exactly come on for
me
it was ursula from the little mermaid
yeah i don't know what it was man i
think that character
little five-year-old eric watched that
movie yeah there's just something about
ursula i mean they she's super sexy the
way they animated her in the woods she
wasn't her looks
divine's voice actually was just like
her pretty face
her pretty face don't forget the
importance of body
language yeah she has that little moment
where she's like life's full of tough
choices in it and you were like gay
[Music]
she's just super curvy and sexual and
like down with whatever she's a diva for
sure
so that's funny some men are boob men
some men are butt men eric is a tentacle
man
hey i gotta be honest tommy that movie
programmed me from a young age
imprinted me so that later i would see
things like you know
pirates of the caribbean dead man's
chest and then the giant kraken comes up
and then like
you see those tentacle suckers just like
and i was like what am i feeling right
now
so this this explains why whenever eric
and i get sushi you demand that we get
calamari
that's so weird i'm a squid boy i'm a
little squid boy
i i mean i wanted her to win that yeah
yeah like
when she like burst out of the human
body and her squids just
slap on that deck i was like something
something is stirring on me prince eric
penetrates yeah that's right
[Music]
it's just it's weird i get it it's weird
i
i wanted her to win and she didn't hey
you know what there's always sequels
right
maybe she'll win in the live-action
version maybe the live-action version
will address that ariel's supposed to be
like 13 in
the book yeah and that's not okay i i
remember
summertime i'd be playing in the
backyard and jumping in our pool
and i would look through the window and
watch my sister and a friend watching
the little mermaid and i would wait for
the moment where ursula would come in
and i'd run inside and just stand in the
living room and be like
and then she would leave and then i'd
jump back in the pool and wait like oh
it's a final battle and i would like
quickly dry off and like slip across the
floor yeah it's like a watch and be like
eric what are you doing and i'm like
shut up shut up it's almost done i just
i just love watching her lose
that's it i love it
and then she gets electrocuted in her
jawbone yeah fills in
her whole jowls yeah it's like the
fattest jawbone you've ever seen
there's so many weird things with the
animation in that movie she had some
thick
jaw bones in that movie um she she gets
it she gets it she gets me
yes and i i'll never get her what an
absolute unit
well before this gets too weird that is
our episode
of big question so great to chat with
you tommy thanks for breaking down
batman's detective skills and to show us
that there's room to grow
absolutely we can all improve a reminder
that you can join our official discord
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars where you can ask
us these questions directly it's where
we're most likely to see your questions
you can also get an audio version of the
show by subscribing to new rockstars big
question wherever you get your podcast
and you can send us your big questions
on twitter using the hashtag bigquestion
you can follow me at eavos follow
tommy tommy bechdel to follow new
rockstars on socials
and uh make sure to subscribe hit that
notification bell and we'll see you next
week
[Music]
you